in der vergangenen Woche habe ich hier
die ungeimpften symbolisch und
Verzeihung gebeten wegen der Hetze und
der Diskriminierung der sie über viele
Monate ausgesetzt waren die Reaktion war
überwältigend ist und zum Teil sehr
emotional ich habe daraus gelernt über
dieses Thema müssen wir öffentlich reden
es ist notwendig dass wir besprechen
dass es Millionen von Menschen gibt in
Deutschland die zutiefst verletzt sind
weil andere Millionen sich überhaupt
nicht um geschert haben was mit ihnen
passiert das geht nicht weiter so und
haben die Medien auch eine ganz ungute
Rolle gespielt es gibt viele Übergriffe
aus den Medien ich will ein paar
erwähnen im Morgenmagazin des ZDF sind
ungeimpfte als Verfassungsfeinde
bezeichnet worden beim Berliner
Tagesspiegel ist der wunderbare
Kolumnist Harald Martenstein aus dem
Blatt geekelt worden weil er geschrieben
hatte wenn ungeimpfte mit dem Judenstern
auf Demonstrationen z dann seid das zwar
anmaßend aber nicht antisemitisch das
ist zweifelsfrei richtig aus meiner
Sicht dann sind beim rbb die ungeimpften
Mitarbeiter über Nacht aus dem Sender
geworfen worden das ist am Tag vor
Weihnachten verkündet worden ich
persönlich bin in einem rufmörderischen
Artikel als Schutzpatron der ungeimpften
bezeichnet worden das hatte die Absicht
mich journalistisch zu erledigen ich
weiß also ein bisschen wovon ich rede
aber ich bin ja geimpft und nicht
ungeimpft und ich finde wir müssen hier
wir müssen hier öffentlich etwas für
diese Menschen tun der Bundespräsident
hat dazu zunächst mal muss ich einwerfen
wir haben uns ja inzwischen was die
Basis der ganzen Diskussion angeht daran
gewöhnt wir haben eingesehen dass es was
die
infektionsleistung angeht also die
Ansteckungsgefahr angeht keinen
Unterschied zwischen geimpfen und
ungeimpften gibt und das ist außerdem
in den in den
Intensivstationen geimpfte neben
ungeimpften liegen da können wir gar
keinen Unterschied mehr feststellen
trotzdem wird aber diese Kampagne gegen
die ungeimpften fortgesetzt ich möchte
einen Satz aus der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung vom gesamt
vom vergangenen Wochenende vorlesen
Zitat und wer sich bis heute keine
Spritze hat geben lassen die Maßnahmen
für übertrieben und das Virus für
harmlos hält sollte ohnehin nicht der
Erste sein der seine Freiheit
zurückbekommt das ist ein ungeheuerer
Satz das heißt in diesem Land gibt es
zwei Sorten von Freiheit die erste
Klasse haben diejenigen die sie haben
impfen lassen und die zweite Klasse
haben vielleicht diejenigen die sich
nicht am impfen lassen der
Bundespräsident hat kürzlich gesagt
es gäbe eine der hat die die Stille
Mehrheit wie er es genannt hat im Land
aufgerufen sie sollten sich zu Wort
melden mit der stillen Mehrheit meinte
er die geimpften die sollten sich gegen
die ungeimpften zu Worte melden ich
finde eher selbst sollte sich zu Wort
melden um den ungeimpften ihre Rechte
zurückzugeben und ihnen Gerechtigkeit
widerfahren zu lassen wir brauchen kein
Bundespräsidenten der eine Mehrheit
auffiegelt wir brauchen einen der die
Minderheit schützt
also zu dem Thema kann ich nur sagen so
wie ich es lebe und auch eigentlich die
meisten in meinem Umfeld ich war halte
mich so dass ich möglichst andere nicht
gefährde
und sind sie denn geimpft ich bin
Geburtstag und ich werde mich auch ein
viertes Mal ich werde wenn es jemand
sagt der von Medizin mehr Ahnung hat als
ich und das sind ganz viele und wenn die
sagen du musst dich zweimal im Jahr
impfen lassen dann werde ich es machen
nicht nur zum eigenen Schutz sondern
auch um sicher zu gehen dass mein Umfeld
geschützt ist und auch
uns dabei zu unterstützen dass die
Pandemie irgendwann vorbei ist dass wir
ein annähernd normales Leben führen
können dass wir auf Partys gehen können
dass wir wieder Spaß haben können dass
ich nicht wenn ich im Zug sitze ein
Versprechen was nie eingelöst wurde also
geimpft und gebustert und was ja also
das und trotzdem dürfen die Leute ja
nicht ich finde es schlimm dass ich fünf
Stunden im Zug sitzen muss mit einer
Maske und mir ist dann übel hinterher
und ich will dass das irgendwann mal
aufhört und ich tue alles dafür dass das
irgendwann mal aufhört für uns hier in
Deutschland und das ist mir wichtiger
als dass es eventuell eine Nebenwirkung
gibt oder dass ich meine demokratische
Freiheit ausleben kann mir ist alles
andere wichtiger als diese beiden Punkte
die ich eben oftmals höre und vor allen
Dingen wie gehe ich auch nicht auf die
Straße und
demonstriere und ich lassen erstmal ich
will auch keine Menschen keine Politiker
tätig angreifen weil die andere Meinung
sind dass ich möchte das meine Meinung
respektiert wird genauso wie ich auch
die Meinung der ungeimpften respektiere
und sage wenn du da Ängste hast und es
nicht machen willst aus irgendwelchen
Gründer mach es nicht so sehe ich das
auch das Schlimme ist dass die die
Pandemie bei manchen die Sehnsucht nach
Einfachheit sich dann so auswirkt
moralische Rigorosität Sündenbock suche
Sündenbock denken einerseits muss ich in
Jorges ein bisschen widersprechen es
gibt schon noch einen Unterschied bei
der Viruslast und auch bei der Schwere
der Erkrankung zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften aber trotzdem für mich ist
ganz wichtig als Liberale es ist die
Entscheidung von erwachsenen Menschen
selbst welche medizinischen Eingriffe
sie an sich vornehmen lassen und das
muss ich respektieren und der
Unterschied ist allerdings unter Omicron
erst recht nicht mehr so stark
was das Thema Infektionsrisiko und so
weiter angeht deshalb bin ich gegen eine
Impfpflicht ich glaube auch nicht
übrigens dass manche ungeimpften die
sich so ein bisschen jetzt allgemein als
Opfer stilisieren oder als seien sie
mündiger als alle die sich geimpft haben
das ist genauso falsch aber ich habe was
gegen diese Suche nach Sündenböcken und
ganz gefährlich an dem was sie gerade
zitiert haben ist nämlich diese denke
als ginge es um Bestrafung oder
Belohnung im freiheitlichen Rechtsstaat
ist das keine Frage von Gnade oder
Wohlwollen ob man Freiheit hat sondern
der Staat darf nur so wenig wie möglich
so viel wie unbedingt nötig die
Freiheitsrechte einschränken und da und
das ist einfach so schlimm dieses
bevormundende dieses erzieherische
dieser Impetus und der greift immer mehr
um sich wir müssen noch mal erkennen
dass wir unsere Erwartungen ans impfen
ich bin genauso wie sie geboostet
ständig zurückgenommen haben anfangs
haben wir gedacht wenn wir geimpft sind
stecken wir uns auch gar nicht mehr an
und wir können auch andere nicht
anstecken das wurde auch übrigens mit
der maskenpflicht verbunden dann haben
wir gemerkt das stimmt ja gar nicht
sondern wir sind als gebustertes selber
in der Lage andere Menschen anzustecken
ich habe im Moment meine beiden Töchter
und deren Männer sind alle geboostet und
alle Corona krank im selben Moment die
haben gar keinen Umgang mit ungeimpften
weil sie da drauf achten das haben sie
also von GMX bekommen
ich werde ab jetzt nur noch sagen
Menschen die sich gegen die Impfung
entschieden haben
geimpft ungeimpft sind glaube ich zwei
Plaketten die wir wieder rauskriegen
dass der Gesellschaft zu kompliziert
wenn ich hier so einen kleinen Vortrag
halte dann muss ich einen einfachen
Begriff dafür haben und es ist wird
jeder verstehen dass ich ihn nicht böse
meine tue ich auch nicht also wir haben
uns dann immer weiter zurückgezogen bis
auf den jetzigen letzten bis auf die
letzte Insel dass wir sagen wir geimpft
ist ist jedenfalls geschützt vom
schweren Krankheitsverlauf das stimmt
auch nicht ganz weil das Liegen
gebusterte auf den Intensivstationen die
auch schwer krank sind und es sterben
auch geboostet also ist alles sehr
fragwürdig ich will jetzt nichts gegens
impfen sagen bin dreimal geimpft aber
jedenfalls die sich nicht am impfen
lassen dafür verantwortlich machen dass
das dass der die Infektionsraten und
dass das Land nicht rauskommt aus der
Pandemie das ist eine wirklich üble
Geschichte
ist das schwarz-weiß ich den
Bundespräsidenten die Impfung bringt
weder den absoluten Ausgang aus der
Pandemie wie ist die Impfpflicht
Befürworter behaupten aber es ist auch
falsch wie es die Impfgegner behaupten
dass sie nichts nütze und nicht sinnvoll
sein sie ist für die allermeisten
Menschen in sinnvoller Schutz vor einem
schweren Verlauf aber sie bringt eben
nicht den völligen die völlige
Sicherheit und den völligen Ausgang aus
der Familie
differenzieren ich habe gemerkt an dem
was das an Reaktionen kam auf meine
Bitte um Verzeihung das war eine
symbolische Geschichte wir haben hier
immer Nena und ich haben immer der
Verunglimpfung der der nicht geimpften
widersprochen aber
dass die ungeimpften die dich da
gemeldet haben
rechtsradikal wären oder
Verschwörungstheoretiker oder sonstige
Spinner das kann ich nicht sagen sondern
ich glaube mein Eindruck war das sind
Menschen aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft
und das müssen wir endlich mal begreifen
dass das keine Randfiguren sind
irgendwie obskur sondern sind mitten aus
der Gesellschaft das sind Ärzte dabei
Rechtsanwälte Krankenschwestern das
wissen wir doch alles Krankenpfleger die
jeweils ihrer individuelle Begründung
haben warum sie nicht impfen lassen
möchten das ist auch ein gutes Recht
weil das ist nicht vorgeschrieben und
dann müssen wir sie auch verteidigen und
dürfen sie nicht so niedermachen lassen
wie das passiert ist
Schutzpatron der Menschen die sich gegen
die Impfung entschieden haben doch
eigentlich ein Kompliment anlegen aber
es war damals in vernichtender Absicht
geschrieben weil damals las sich das so
Wertung der die ungeimpften und in unter
seinen Schutzmantel nimmt der ist ein
ganz
typisches Zeichen unserer finde ich
nicht nicht mehr gut Debattenkultur das
nicht mehr über die Qualität der
Argumente beurteilt wird was jemand sagt
sondern darüber wer dafür Beifall
klatscht ist ein Riesenproblem auch für
Politiker man kann das richtige sagen
und man von den falschen Leuten Beifall
kriegt wird es darüber diffamiert und
das ist falsch wir müssen doch in der
Sache argumentieren und die Qualität der
Argumente auseinander nehmen und nicht
danach irgendwie sich richten wer
applaudiert oder nicht sonst gibt man
übrigens auch den falschen Leuten die
ganz große Deutungsarbeit denjenigen die
noch bestimmen was man sagen darf oder
was nicht wir müssen über die Qualität
der Argumente streiten genau dann
brauche ich noch ein sachliches Argument
einbringen
und zwar der Hauptgrund warum überhaupt
über eine Impfpflicht gesprochen wurde
oder wo man ermutigt wurde sich zu
impfen das war bevor überhaupt ein
Impfstoff da war hat man gedacht
hoffentlich kommt eine hoffentlich kommt
einer es gab vor zwei Jahren her da hat
man sich geimpft wie sie gerade gesagt
haben und dann dachte man nach der
zweiten Impfung alles gut so wurde es ja
vom vorherigen Gesundheitsminister auch
propagiert dann hieß es okay das Reich
ist doch nicht man braucht eine dritte
Impfung aber es Hauptargument wo es
immer ging warum muss man oder soll man
sich impfen oder warum gibt es ein
Lockdown weil die Intensivstation
komplett überlastet sind das teile ich
nach wie vor wenn die Intensivstation
überlastet sind dann bricht das
Gesundheitssystem zusammen habe ich
erwarte ja von dem Staat insbesondere
von dem deutschen Staat ja
dass er dafür in der Lage ist das
Gesundheitssystem
so in wie sagt man auf in schachtwahl
oder so modern zu führen das genau hier
kann Engpass entsteht ja und das ist die
Hauptaufgabe vom Gesundheitsminister
nicht dass er uns einschränkt ja nicht
dass er uns hier einschränkt damit
sondern er ist dafür verantwortlich
nicht noch mal Lockdown noch mal
Einschränkungen und jetzt schon wieder
erzählen in drei oder was im September
Oktober kommt dann die vierte Welle
irgendwann wird es ja schon wieder
Impfung